well on this black friday so many of us
are just rushing to stores and some have
like a kind of a gear head in mind so we
want to know some good car gadgets and
joining us with the best advice dr frank
vigiano good morning dr frank
good morning nate how are you my friend
i'm sticking with mostly sunny how about
you
oh same way buddy i'm sticking with you
excellent so i understand we're starting
out with uh something about a soft top
what kind of a an item are we talking
about here
yeah this is pretty cool you know a lot
of people have jeeps they have wranglers
and they also have a new bronco and why
not give them the gift of open-air
driving with great adventure with a soft
top and best stop is the company that
basically has manufactured most of these
cool soft tops that are available
and you can buy a soft top for your jeep
wrangler your truck or your new ford
bronco they have something called simply
the best holiday it's a special and it's
a promotion that now runs through cyber
monday with savings up to 150
which is amazing
and they have home installation it's
available through next spring which
means you can still buy it now install
it in the spring at your home when it's
convenient for you
and when the weather turns much warmer
and you can find these at bestop.com
visit them and remember it's called
simply the best holiday promo again 150
off on their soft tops man those new
broncos are amazing have you seen the
video of those broncos man
oh yeah they're they're wonderful
they're fun okay so next up we don't
have this problem out here a whole lot
but i bet you we have family or friends
that would probably like something that
they would never think of an electric
ice scraper how does that work yeah
well you know it's funny too because
when i'm out there in january every once
in a while i see a frost on the windows
so you may not use it every day like we
do back here but this is really cool
it's made by karcher it's called the
edi4 electric ice scraper so it's an
effortless way to clean the vehicle
windshield or windows compared to
traditional ice scrapers it removes ice
in a single motion even when cleaning
thick layers of ice this is really cool
and it's designed and it rotates at 500
rpms with special blades that are
designed for high performance uh they it
uses a lithium-ion battery the runtime
is 15 minutes it's 79.99
at karcher.com and basically you'll be
able to get free shipping as well
wow so the for the folks that have
issues with ice like you said maybe once
in a while here but back east if you've
got friends who need it that would be a
really good deal okay one of the things
that we always have to check in with our
cars dr frank is tires make such a
difference tell us about these uh
continental vikings
yeah they really do and again you know
these are tires in fact continental
they're celebrating by the way their
150th anniversary which is pretty
amazing they've been around a long time
made great product but their premium
winter tire for passenger cars and
trucks and suvs and light trucks it has
polar plus technology it's called the
viking contact 7. it provides flexible
tread and cold temperatures better grip
in winter conditions and shorter
stopping distances on ice and snow
and prices determined by the dealer but
you can get more information at
continental tire dot com
okay well we'll look for those now dr
frank a lot of folks are getting these
electric cars and some people are a
little hesitant because they wouldn't be
they're afraid that they won't be able
to find a place to charge their electric
vehicle this next product uh fixes that
problem
that's correct and you know battery
range anxiety nate is a true
threat i mean people when they drive
they go oh my goodness am i going to be
able to charge the car just as you
mentioned this is buy a cell it's a
portable electric vehicle charger it
basically is a level two so it charges
much faster than level one it's perfect
for all usb cars including tesla you can
use it indoors or outdoors it doesn't
matter and it comes with a 24 foot cable
and a case you can take it with you what
i like is no matter where you are you
just plug this into a standard outlet
standard receptacle and you can charge
the vehicle it's available at costco.com
and also at amazon and it's 429.99
so the only key here is access to a
regular outlet this is not something
that you'd be out in the middle of
nowhere with this thing you still have
to plug it in but it uses a regular
outlet
right because if you're searching for
charging stations today then you're in a
situation where nothing's really close
you simply can pull over even if you're
going to eat and go to a restaurant and
as long as there is an ac ac120 outlet
because there's an adapter that comes
with the unit you can plug it in
anywhere it's one of the best products
i've found i really like that idea of
going to have dinner and then your car
is charging so there you go why not
absolutely hey dr frank always a
pleasure talking to you we're out of
time for right now but we are looking
forward to seeing you here in las vegas
for the consumer electronics show in
january thanks dr frank
you bet see you in january nate